jan i know it's a difficult
uh moment in game thank you so much for
uh joining us and
some questions will certainly be
be difficult so they need to be asked
first a question i have
uh is about the mistake of why did it
happen
well i don't think those questions are
difficult because uh
yeah basically
in
uh you know in another iteration it
would be a draw like in 15 moves after
queen one check queen e7
uh yeah but
i would say it was like a change of
slightly weird decisions so starting
with king f8 yeah like this was like
some somewhat more
artificial than just queen e7 yeah
trading away the queens and uh basically
finishing the game quickly
uh but uh that's uh that wasn't actually
um such such a big deal i think it's
still very
very natural position like it's almost
equal but yeah perhaps after h4 c4 it
became slightly slightly unpleasant some
perhaps instead of h4 i could just
change the queen like with queen d6 i
intending rookie 6 so it would also be
closer to equality and well uh i mean
indeed b5 uh was just a very bad wonder
uh but uh i believe uh at that moment
the position became like slightly
unpleasant but still it was
uh i believe positive draw
but i mean of course after b5 it's uh
well probably i didn't defend in the
best way but uh
it becomes really unpleasant and i guess
uh
frankly speaking it's uh it's hard to
defend after such uh such a blunder
what
uh what did you overlook you you did you
see the queen a3 check thread and
thought there was something that you had
as a counter or yeah i mean indeed i saw
it but uh i forgot that in the lion king
jade queen a7 btc4 actually bishop is
hanging here so but
once again at this moment it's
especially after dxe4 it's not as you
know straightforward draw as it used to
be